هذا وقد دانه رئاسه الفلسطينيه والاقتحام
الاسرائيليه لمخيم بلاطه ومدينه نابلس
وقال الناطق باسم الرئاسه نبيله بوردين
اينما حدث في المخيم مجزره حقيقيه
واستمرار للحرب الشامله على الشعب
الفلسطيني وحمل ابو ردينا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه الكامله عن هذا
التصعيد المستمر والجرائم المستمره وسياسه
العقاب الجماعي بحسب تعبيره وطلب ابو
ردينه الاداره الامريكيه بالتدخل الفوري
لوقف ما وصفه بالجنون الاسرائيلي مضيفا ان
صمت الاداره الامريكيه شجع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على التمادي في عدوانه
بدورها قالت حركه حماس سن الجريمه البشعه
التي ارتكبتها القوات الاحتلال في مخيم
بلاطه فجر اليوم لن تؤثر في معنويات الشعب
الفلسطيني
المنتفضه للرد على جرائم الاحتلال
والانتصار للمسجد الاقصى والمقدسات التي
تتعرض للتدنيس والتهويد